franck ferrand raconte sur radio
classique
depuis le diacre montant s'il à
versailles franck ferrand raconte la
grande histoire de versailles celle de
la ville pour radio classique le
journaliste a enregistré 5 émission
entièrement dédié à la cité royale
une première sur cette antenne nous
allons commencer par un sujet que
j'allais dire d'actualité en tout cas de
résonance mémorielle puisqu'il s'agit de
la paix de 1919 et ce traité de
versailles le fameux traité de
versailles
on va raconter les circonstances de la
signature de ce traité
et puis ensuite ce sera le grand
déroulement de l'histoire vers sa gamme
de la création de la ville par louis xiv
aux grands noms de l'histoire inspirée
par la cité franck ferrand retraçant
versailles qui le passionne le
journaliste qui a vécu trois ans en l'an
2000 je commençais à envisager d'écrire
sur versailles avait énormément de
choses que j'avais à dire que levet
accumulées depuis des années des années
une documentation phénoménal j'étais
devenu l'ami des conservateurs du
château j'avais beaucoup de d'ouverture
dans certains fonds d'archivés bref il
fallait que j'écrive et je me suis dit
que le mieux ce serait de le faire ici
même pour écouter les émissions il
faudra patienter encore quelques jours
première diffusion le 10 juin à 9 heures
et 14 heures sur radio classique